In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for November 1st, on which we commemorate.
The Holy and Wonderworking on Mercenaries, Cosmas and Damien.
On the first of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Mercenaries and Wonder
Workers, Cosmas and Damien.
And Cosmas and Damien were brothers according to the flesh and came from the region of Ephesus
in the province of Asia.
Sometime after they were born, their father, a pagan of noble lineage, embraced the Christian
faith.
But his early death left the two children at the sole care of their devout mother, Thildota,
who had been a Christian since childhood.
She made every effort to bring up her sons in Piety by her own virtuous example.
Cosmas and Damien were educated in the various branches of learning of their day.
But turned away before long, from all vain knowledge, to devote themselves to the art
of medicine, that they might free their neighbors from every sickness and infirmity.
Despite the apostles sent forth by Christ, they were given the power to cast out unclean
spirits and to heal all manner of sickness with no other remedy than their prayer.
Having freely received the grace of the Holy Spirit, these new apostles freely gave.
They tended the rich just as they did the poor and strangers as their own relatives, asking
nothing in return.
Their charity was such that their care extended even to animals.
So closely did they link the preaching of the gospel of salvation to healing, that although
they were qualified in medical science, they used by way of remedy neither Lancet nor Plaster,
but only the life-giving name of Christ, so that the Savior himself was the physician, who
working in them, healed souls and bodies.
Patients made their way from all quarters to their dwelling, and each one found healing and
comfort according to the measure of his faith.
Saint Damien, the younger brother, was the first to fall asleep in peace, followed sometime
later by Saint Cosmas.
Later after, crowds of Christians came in a constant stream to the church built over
their tomb, at a place called Firmann.
Their precious relics and their icon were an abundant source of healing for the sick, who were
allowed to spend several days in the church, surrounded by prayers and supplications.
No one left without obtaining either a cure or the strength to bear with patience and hope,
the illness permitted by God for the salvation of his soul, through the prayers of our holy
fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.